the country has just taken part in a
giant democratic exercise perhaps the
biggest in our history over 33 million
people from England Scotland Wales
Northern Ireland and Gibraltar have all
had their say we should be proud of the
fact that in these islands we trust the
people with these big decisions we not
only have a parliamentary democracy but
on questions about the arrangements for
how we're governed there are times when
it is right to ask the people themselves
and that is what we have done the
British people have voted to leave the
European Union and their will must be
respected I want to thank everyone who
took part in the campaign on my side of
the argument including all those who put
put aside party differences to speak in
what they believed was the national
interest and let me congratulate all
those who took part in the leave
campaign for the spirited and passionate
case that they made the will of the
British people is an instruction that
must be delivered it was not a decision
that was taken lightly not least because
so many things were said by so many
different organizations about the
significance of this decision so there
can be no doubt about the result across
the world people have been watching the
choice that Britain has made I would
reassure those markets and investors
that Britain's economy is fundamentally
strong and I would also reassure Brits
living in European countries and
European citizens living here that there
will be no immediate changes in your
circumstances there will be no initial
change in the way our people can travel
in the way our goods can move or the way
our services can be sold we must now
prepare for a negotiation with the
European Union this will need to involve
the full engagement of the Scottish
Welsh and Northern Ireland governments
to ensure that the interests of all
parts of our United Kingdom
are protected and advanced but above all
this will require strong determined and
committed leadership I'm very proud and
very honored to have been prime minister
of this country for six years I believe
we've made great steps with more people
in work than ever before in our history
with reforms to welfare and education
increasing people's life chances
building a bigger and stronger society
keeping our promises to the poorest
people in the world and enabling those
who love each other to get married
whatever their sexuality but above all
restoring Britain's economic strength
and I'm grateful to everyone who's
helped to make that happen I've also
always believed that we have to confront
big decisions not dark them that is why
we delivered the first coalition
government in 70 years to bring our
economy back from the brink it's why we
delivered a fair legal and decisive
referendum in Scotland and it's why I
made the pledge to renegotiate Britain's
position in the European Union and to
hold a referendum on our membership and
have carried those things out I fought
this campaign in the only way I know how
which is to say directly and
passionately what I think and feel head
heart and soul I held nothing back I was
absolutely clear about my belief that
Britain is stronger safer and better off
inside the European Union and I made
clear the referendum was about this and
this alone not the future of any single
politician including myself but the
British people have made a very clear
decision to take a different path and as
such I think the country requires fresh
leadership to take it in this direction
I will do everything I can as Prime
Minister to steady the ship over the
coming weeks and months but I do not
think it would be right for me to try to
be the captain
that steers our country to its next
destination this is not a decision I've
taken lightly but I do believe it's in
the national interest to have a period
of stability and then the new leadership
required there is no need for a precise
timetable today but in my view we should
aim to have a new prime minister in
place by the start of the conservative
party conference in october delivering
stability will be important and i will
continue in post as prime minister with
my cabinet for the next three months the
cabinet will meet on monday the governor
of the Bank of England is making a
statement about the steps that the bank
and the Treasury are taking to reassure
financial markets we will also continue
taking forward the important legislation
that we set before Parliament in the
Queen's Speech and I've spoken to her
majesty the queen this morning to advise
our of the steps that I'm taking a
negotiation with the European Union will
need to begin under a new prime minister
and I think it's right that this new
prime minister takes the decision about
when to trigger article 50 and start the
formal and legal process of leaving the
EU I will attend the European Council
next week to explain the decision the
British people have taken and my own
decision the British people have made a
choice that not only needs to be
respected but those on the losing side
of the argument myself included should
help to make it work Britain is a
special country we have so many great
advantages a parliamentary democracy
where we resolve great issues about our
future through peaceful debate a great
trading nation with our science and arts
our engineering and our creativity
respected the world over and while we
are not perfect I do believe we can be a
model of a multiracial multi-faith
democracy where people can come and make
a contribution and rise to the very
highest that their talent allows
although leaving Europe was not the path
i recommend it I am the first to praise
our incredible strengths I said before
that Britain can survive outside the
european union and indeed that we could
find a way now the decision has been
made to leave we need to find the best
way and I will do everything I can to
help I love this country and I feel
honored to have served it and I will do
everything I can in future to help this
great country succeed